it is march 10 2022 and you're watching
the code report typescript will turn 10
years old in october of this year in the
early days it was only used by squares
working at big mega corporations today
even that dude at the coffee shop with a
man bun drinking a soy latte coding on
his m1 macbook as loving typescript on
the state of javascript survey types
were the number one missing feature
apparently people like to catch bugs
before they get shipped to production
but there's still one thing that we can
all agree to hate about typescript the
build step or transpiling your
typescript code back into vanilla
javascript it takes time and requires
you to think about annoying
configuration details wouldn't it be
nice if typescript just worked in the
browser without a build step well that
dream might become a reality someday
because the team behind typescript just
submitted a tc39 proposal that would
bring native types into the ecmascript
standard aka the javascript programming
language before you celebrate though
keep in mind that many tc39 proposals
fail and this is just at stage zero
which means it hasn't even been
presented to the important people yet a
proposal needs to go through four stages
before it gets implemented into the
ecmascript standard this process can
take years and it may never get there at
all back in the early 2000s there was a
version of javascript called es4 it was
going to include a type system but
everybody disagreed on it so much that
they just threw that entire version of
javascript in the garbage and skipped
ahead to es5 that was probably for the
best because today typescript gives us a
very good idea of what a type system for
javascript should look like but does
that mean that every browser and runtime
like node.js will need to implement the
typescript compiler no actually the way
it works is pretty clever if we look
closely the proposal says types as
comments in javascript you can use js
dot comments in vanilla javascript then
use a ts check comment to get type
checking in a plain javascript file
that's pretty cool because you get the
awesome intellisense of typescript
without the need for a build step
because comments are totally ignored by
the browser the drawback is that nobody
wants to write comments like this
they're really clunky and awkward what
the proposal aims to do is add an
optional syntax to javascript that would
be totally ignored by any engine that
runs the code just like a comment that
means you could add type annotations to
your code but the code would run just
like regular javascript because the type
annotations are treated just like
comments but can be used by tools like
typescript flow and your ide to provide
an awesome developer experience it's a
very non-invasive approach that could be
implemented without tearing apart the
existing javascript ecosystem let's take
a moment to pray for its success
[Music]
in other news react 18 is now a release
candidate its big new feature is
concurrent rendering which opens up new
ui design patterns with suspense also
apple just released a new desktop
computer called the mac studio with a
ridiculous 20 core m1 ultra chip and an
even more ridiculous 4 000 price tag
don't worry though that'll look cheap
pretty soon because inflation just set a
new 40-year high today not to worry
though your friends over at the federal
reserve are coming out this strong with
a quarter percentage rate hike maybe at
some point in the future this has been
the code report thanks for watching and
i will see you in the next one